Speaker 1: Donald Trump did threaten death and
destruction in a dangerous 1 a.m. rant the other
night. This is very scary stuff. Trump posting to
truth social quote. What kind of person can charge
another person in this case a former president
of the United States who got more votes than any
sitting president in history and leading candidate
by far for the Republican Party nomination with
a capital C crime when it is known by all that
no crime has been committed and also known that
potential death and destruction in such a false
charge could be catastrophic for our capital C,
Country Y. And who would do such a
thing? Only a degenerate psychopath
that truly hates the USA. This is Donald
Trump saying If Alvin Bragg indicts me,
it will lead to death and destruction for the
country and it will be Alvin Bragg's fault,
not Trump's fault, for inciting the death and
destruction, or I guess the people who commit
the death and destruction for listening
to Trump. Extremely scary stuff. The New
York Times reporting Trump Escalating attacks
raises Specter of violence If he is charged
and media reporting about Donald Trump making a
post where he's holding a baseball bat seemingly
threatening himself, the district attorney Alvin
Bragg, which Trump subsequently deleted. I hope
there is not violence, but I am very worried
that there will be because of the direction this
is going. My only thought is it actually seems
like Trump's supporters aren't that motivated
to go out and protest and commit commit acts of
violence. They seem sort of resigned in a way.
Let's hope they are lazy and pacified and don't
heed Trump's calls. That's the hope right now.